[音楽]
市町数
ファッション頭痛
今
皆さんは
何を聞いたんでしょう
音
サウンドでい
響
ラジなんですん
振動
バイブレーション
桐生
as to me
記憶
メモリー
を
my voice し
もしくは
私の声
超えて一体何でしょう
音って一体
何でしょう
聞こえるってへ
大どういうことでしょう
warez ボイス俺でさん
エルウェーじぇい
姫
私は
声で空間を認識します
安楽の一スペースっば友禅 my voice over
コウモリが自分の獲物を音波を発して認識するように
声を発します
r
あ
ああ
ただ体を静かにして耳を澄ますだけではなくて
自分を取り巻く環境に
手を伸ばすように
声を発します
i プロデュースマイルヴォイッジ fih
会う2 n bar moon アラームいい
そして声の反射を受け止めて
この空間がどんな響きの ea を持っているのかを
丁寧に
感じ取っていきます
with リフレクションの甘い音ボイシ
i pussy ふたぁグラデーション大フ
れそうなんです
going on ででスパイス1
バイオ1
ああああああ
ないです
掴み経営者のん icom に帰る weather
スペース
空間とコミュニケーションをとるんです
空間は
どんな形をしているかどんな
構造しているかそしてどんな材質によってできているかによって
雇用の響きを持っています
sp スクレーストゥヌドめぞん図2
ベリーシュレーディンガー音シェイプ asapen ディストラクションどぅ
materials
例えば境界を思い浮かべてみてください
教会の中に一歩
入ると
何とも言えない上に登っていくような響きを感じたことがないでしょうか
スペーサズベン宣言
空間は
すでに歌っています
おとう聞くとき私は
耳と生態と皮膚を使います
聴覚器官として
ああいうず bun 僕は好意スキン
うないヒールさウンジュ
サウンドメーカーバイブレーションあーコーン b 4サイズ oso to skin
ポール all my パリー
整体
良い音2アウトこの度の多くの正体が一緒に振動しているように感じます
それから皮膚
私の友人に耳の聞こえないダンサーがいますが彼は幼い頃から
を超気を付けずに育ったので
全身がセンサーみたいになっていますなので一緒に踊ってくれる時は私の声を
皮膚で感じ取ってくれます
彼ほどではないんですけど私も
皮膚で
世界に耳を傾けますなのでよく聞こうとするときは後無意識に腕まくりを
することが多いです
て
世界はこの
壁の向こうそれから天井の向こうそして床の奥へと
付いています
ど r fx ファンディンオーバーオールオーバーオールシールん nb ローブ4
の空間を
書と絵音がここに届いてくるのではなくて
ことによって
聞くことで外へ跳躍します
あなたは
聞こえるところまで
拡張することが
できます
猫地下なので難しいんですけど
空調の少しの高2
音楽の演奏がありますそして無効
よりもう少し風が強くなって
外にある
プラスチックの何かと壁の間に緩みができてその間を
風が通って何かを頭立てているような
それから
少し木が揺れている
拡張していきます
って自分を取り巻くをと一つ一つと接続してネットワークします
connect ブレイズ
エブリィスイングオーバーのペスサウンズ
アラウンドに病んだ合わんと言う
そのネットワークの中で音たちは
並列に存在し始めます
距離と時間を失って
並列になりますそれはあたかも
夜空の星が
遠く近く光を届けてくるんだけれど私たちのこの夜空の転厩では
並びますよねこんな風に音が並列に私の意識のフィールドに並びます
歌っている時私はその数兆個の星たちすべてに触って高速で新しい星座を作り続けて
いるような感覚になります
with stars サウンズ集
クレープ new コンストレーションずスーツ
アルゴリズム明日6 e
それは
私というアルゴリズムです
その
音の海に飛び込んでどこまでが私でどこからが海なのか
わからないぐらいに溶け合って
そしてでも不意にまた
星座をつくっている自分に戻ってきたりします
どこまでが世界でどこからが私
世界私
あなたが世界を聴いているとき
世界もあなたは聞いています
w rss 2
終わり売り新茶ルオー
あなたが聞けば
世界は歌い出す
1収支+ to listen to roll 大
たワールドした後年件
宣言
れんげんぐ&宣言
と発生している私の声は聞こえなくなった後音として聞こえなくなった後どこへ行くん
でしょ
一度振動した空気は一度温められた空気は音として聞こえなくなった後も
あなたのそばにいて
ただ聞こえないだけかもしれません
滞留する
透明な地層のようにこの世界を満たして
ときにあなたに触れて
感情を与えたり
知恵を
授けてくれるかも
しれないなと思います
ウェア
う前ボイス
ぺ公園
アフターでサピあるならずさん
パスタをの名刺田植えていう
半蔵
ゆーきゃんぷ
ana 2
はあああいう hamar
にふっとパンダですねはい
先発ラグいいんやからキャセイいったのかパチッ
あーいい n
ああああああ
んだよ
r
あれ
lore うわぁ2 o 4
ねっ
[音楽]
air
入ったらチョコに慣らしていこう
ああああああああ
フック
優先とうわーお
ねえん
[音楽]
持って r
じゃ
h がああ
青い n 言った
ハイアール
[音楽]
[拍手]